nadège bonjour donc c'est une nouvelle
mobilisation pour contre les
suppressions d'emplois pour les salariés
de sanofi absolument et c'est une
manifestation qui se met petit à petit
en place ils sont un peu plus d'une
vingtaine de salariés de sanofi a
manifesté devant le siège parisien de
sanofi des salariés qui ont aussi reçu
le soutien d'une vingtaine de salariés
de l'entreprise des hydrocarbures
française total donc on voit là des
manifestants bien acquis à protestent
aujourd'hui contre la suppression de 634
364 emplois dans le secteur du
développement aida de la recherche
sanofi un plan de réduction d'effectifs
qui avait été annoncé en juin dernier
qui a créé bois 1701 suppressions de
postes en europe dont un millier en
france les salariés sont donc au dénonce
cette stratégie aujourd'hui alors que et
bien le groupe pharmaceutique a réalisé
11 milliards de chiffre d'affaires l'an
dernier à distribuer et 4 milliards
d'euros de dividendes à ses actionnaires
donc une situation qu'il juge
incompréhensible avec nous
avec nous laurence cohen qui est
sénatrice pcf du val de marne alors vous
êtes nombreux au sein de votre parti a
apporté votre soutien aux salariés de
sanofi pourquoi bien parce que on est en
pleine période de pandémie et c'est
absolument révoltant de voir que sanofi
qui se tait les profits par milliards et
bien annonce un plan de licenciement
c'est 1000 licenciements en france donc
l'action chercheurs et on ne peut pas ne
pas s'interroger sur le fait que au pays
de pasteur
il n'y est pas du absent contre le le co
lead
le vaccin de sanofi a échoué et que ça
leur pose pas de problème
il continue à dissocier les chercheurs
donc c'est pour dénoncer cette politique
est mortifère mortifère pour les
salariés mortifère finalement pour la
santé publique que je suis ici alors
c'est pas un échec de bâle 1 chez sanofi
puisque on parle d'un retard il annonce
l'arrivée du vaccin de sanofi pour le
quatrième trimestre 2021 donc avec un
retard de quatre mois pour vous c'est un
échec
vaches et surtout extrêmement
significative c'est à dire que c'est
formidable ce qui s'est passé en termes
de recherche dans le monde
la recherche elle est alimentée par les
fonds publics
ça c'est extrêmement important si les
labos qui s'en empare qui donc des tours
dans quelque sorte l'argent public
puisque lors leurs objectifs et
notamment à celles fixées surtout de
verser des dividendes aux actionnaires
donc c'est ça qu'il faut dénoncer c'est
pour ça que je suis ici et c'est pour ça
je porte la proposition avec les députés
communistes et les sénateurs communique
donc de créer un pôle public du
médicament dhs pour faire que les grands
labos privés
n'est pas la même idée que la france
retrouve sa souveraineté en matière
discussion
qui ont signé la motion du midi
j'estime que la france a perdu de sa
valeur de sa valeur d'antan ce qui
concerne le secteur de la recherche et
du développement
non je pense que les chercheurs les
salariés et notamment chez sanofi sont
extrêmement qualifiés mais c'est la
politique qui est menée par ce
laboratoire privé qui est une politique
néfaste et quand je parle d'une ou d'un
échec
j'ai parce que alors que tout le monde
apprend effectivement les traitements
tout le monde attend un vaccin
eh bien ça le fier parce qu'à la trêve
et longtemps faire les moteurs je
dénonce y compris l'abandon d'un certain
nombre médicaments par sanofi jugée non
rentable c'est facilement
problème de la coved donc c'est ce qu'il
faut dénoncer et en même temps porter
des propositions alternatives c'est ce
que je fais merci à laurence cohen je
rappelle que vous êtes sénatrice du
parti communiste français val-de-marne
merci beaucoup pour d'avoir répondu à
nos questions comme vous l'avez entendu
à laurence cohen parlementaire qui
déplore ces nouvelles suppressions de
postes qui veut pousser le gouvernement
à réagir et à soutenir ses salariés de
sanofi
merci beaucoup à vous n'êtes âge
abderrazak pour toutes ces précisions
direct donc du siège de sanofi
[Musique]